Ursprünglich kam die Erkrankung namens “Chagas”
nur in Zentral- und Südamerika vor - doch
jetzt warnen Behörden vor einer globalen
Ausbreitung.
Infiziert werden die Betroffenen durch Raubwanzen
und die Krankheit ist echt nicht ohne - sie
kann im schlimmsten Fall auch zum Tod führen.
Der konkrete Infektionsweg ist aber nur für
Hartgesottene auszuhalten.
Clixoom Science & Fiction, Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Sciene-Videos.
Abonniert den Kanal.
Nur dann verpasst ihr kein Video. herzlich
willkommen!
Achtung!
Jetzt wird’s eklig.
Denn die Wanzen krabbeln in die Nähe der
Augen und des Mundes ihrer Opfer und beginnen
dort Blut zu saugen.
In ihrem Kot befinden sich wiederum Parasiten,
die dann die Infektion an sich hervorrufen.
Mittlerweile ist klar: Die Chagas-Krankheit
ist längst keine Tropenkrankheit mehr, die
nur noch in Südamerika und Mittelamerika
auftritt.
Schätzungen zufolge sind in den Vereinigten
Staaten mindestens 300.000 Menschen betroffen
und auch in Kanada, Japan und Australien tritt
die Erkrankung immer häufiger auf.
Aber eben auch in Europa.
Nach Schätzungen der “American Heart Association”
(AHA) gibt es weltweit mittlerweile sechs
Millionen Infizierte.
Andere Quellen sprechen sogar von 18 Millionen
Infizierten.
Genau deswegen hat die amerikanische Non-Profit-Organisation
gemeinsam mit der “Inter-American Society
of Cardiology” ein Statement herausgegeben,
in denen Ärzte-Teams weltweit dazu aufgerufen
werden, sich über diese Krankheit zu informieren.
Denn nur so kann sichergestellt werden, dass
die steigende Gefahr erkannt und kontrolliert
wird.
Konkret heißt es in der Erklärung: “Gesundheitsdienstleister
und Gesundheitssysteme außerhalb Lateinamerikas
müssen so ausgestattet sein, dass sie die
Chagas-Krankheit erkennen, diagnostizieren
und behandeln und eine weitere Krankheitsübertragung
verhindern können”.
Denn ja: Die Gefahr der Chagas-Infektionen
ist nicht zu unterschätzen.
Dabei klingt der Spitzname der verantwortlichen
Insekten sogar ganz niedlich: “Kissing Bugs”
also Küssende Wanzen nämlich.
Die Raubwanzen sind selbst bis zu vier Zentimeter
groß und dienen als Überträger.
Der Erreger selbst ist ein Einzeller - die
korrekte Bezeichnung lautet “Trypanosoma
cruzi”.
Die Raubwanzen sind nachtaktiv und auf der
Suche nach Blut von schlafenden Säugetieren,
Vögeln, Reptilien oder eben auch Menschen.
Am liebsten stechen sie dort, wo die Haut
besonders dünn ist.
Also in der Mund- oder Augenregion.
Doch die Infektion erfolgt gar nicht durch
den Stich der Raubwanze selbst, sondern durch
ihre Ausscheidungen, die die Erreger enthalten.
Gelangen diese in die frische Stichwunde,
in die Augen oder Schleimhaut der Opfer, sind
diese infiziert.
Der Kot der Wanzen ist nach Einschätzungen
und Forschungsteams sogar für Jahre lang
infektiös.
Bleibt die Infektion unbehandelt, entwickeln
etwa 30 Prozent der Betroffenen Herz- und
Darminfektionen.
Dies kann im schlimmsten Fall auch zu einer
chronischen Form der Erkrankung führen - samt
Herzversagen und der Gefahr eines plötzlichen
Todes.
In der frühen Infektionsphase zeigen manche
Symptome einer Grippe wie Gliederschmerzen
und Fieber.
Doch der Großteil der Betroffenen zeigt nicht
einmal Symptome - so nennen manche Ärzte-Teams
die Erkrankung auch “leisen Mörder”.
Anhand einer Blutuntersuchung zeigt sich allerdings
schnell, ob sich Patienten mit Chagas infiziert
haben.
Dann können Ärzteteams entsprechende Medikamente
verabreichen.
In den USA sind bislang elf Raubwanzen bekannt,
die Chagas übertragen können.
Vor allem in Kalifornien, Texas und Florida
tritt die Krankheit auf.
Durch den weltweiten Tourismus ist sie mittlerweile
fast in allen Ländern dieser Welt vertreten.
Schon vor vier Jahren (2014) hatten Ärzteteams
Alarm geschlagen: Denn schon damals wurde
eine hohe Rate an Chagas-Infizierten festgestellt.
Ebenso auch auch eine hohe Anzahl an Herzerkrankungen,
die mit dieser Krankheit in Zusammenhang stehen.
Das Problem hat laut der Ärzteteams zwei
Dimensionen: Zum einen die rasante Ausbreitung
von Chagas und zum anderen das fehlende Bewusstsein.
Sowohl Diagnose- als auch die Behandlungsmöglichkeiten
seien dringend zu überdenken.
Zudem ist laut der aktuellen Erklärung auch
dringend die Entwicklung neuer Medikamente
notwendig.
Diese sollten zum einen weniger Nebenwirkungen
haben und zudem auch während einer Schwangerschaft
eingenommen werden können.
Dies ist bislang nämlich nicht möglich.
Nur so könne verhindert werden, dass die
Zahl der Infizierten weiter in die Höhe steigt.
Wir halten euch dazu natürlich auf dem Laufenden.
Wenn ihr kein Video dazu und auch zu allen
anderen Themen verpassen wollt, dann abonniert
Clixoom auch auf englisch.
Denn auch da gibt es immer wieder Videopremieren.
Dafür einfach hier draufklicken.
Und hier geht es weiter mit: Can we survive
dying?
- Could we trick death and live forever?
Bis bald hoffentlich auch auf dem englischen
Kanal.
See you soon, stay tuned!